what angers me about the Pro and I don't
call them pro lifers anymore I call them
pro birthers because here's why here's
what angers me they all want to outlaw
abortion and then all these kids come
into the world and yet the same people
take away welfare and they take away the
very safety net that many of these
unwanted children are gonna need to
survive so they give birth and then they
say well you're on your own now well
what's the odds of these unwanted
children becoming successful
I'd say slim to none so if you're
anti-abortion then you should be pro
welfare because somebody's gonna have to
take care in many cases not every child
is born into your perfect Leave It to
Beaver family you know people get
pregnant and but my belief unequivocally
is it's a woman's right to choose
because that woman has to give birth to
that child and that woman has to raise
that child now men play a role too but
women play a larger one in that and and
it's certainly their choice to make and
banning Planned Parenthood or stopping
money for that is ridiculous because if
you're anti-abortion you should be Pro
contraception but yet they're not are
they and you should be if you're
anti-abortion then you should be very
strongly Pro contraception then that's
why I don't call them pro-life anymore I
call them pro birth because they don't
care about them after they're after the
birth there ain't no safety net from
that point